SACHIT MISHRA: Do you want
to get your Chrome web
apps on the big screen?
Well, we've made it
easier than ever before.
Hi, I'm Sachit Mishra from
the Google Developer Relations
team, and I'm going to tell you
about the Cast Sender Framework
API for Chrome.
In October 2016, we launched
the Cast Framework API
for the Google Cast SDK.
The framework API is built on
top of the Cast Center SDK,
and simplifies several
parts of the SDK while
addressing the major pain points
identified by content partners
and developers.
The Cast Framework
API significantly
reduces the amount
of code needed
by providing a UI widget that
fully complies with the Cast UX
design checklist, and a
remote player binding that
is super simple to hook
into your media player
implementation.
First, here's some terminology
about how casting works.
The Google Cast
sender application
refers to Chrome running on
a mobile device or laptop.
And the receiver application
refers to an HTML application
running on Chromecast or other
Google Cast receiver devices.
Now let's take a look
at the typical lifecycle
of a Cast sender app.
When the sender app is
launched, Cast receiver devices
need to be discovered
on the local network.
Once the user selects a
device, the sender app
will connect to that device
and launch the receiver app.
The sender app then
creates a message channel
to the receiver app to
send and receive messages.
The user can also
disconnect from that device.
The new framework API implements
these new features-- a UI Cast
button which handles
its own state
and complies with the Google
Cast design checklist;
a remote player binding for
easy remote media playback;
automatic device discovery,
so that you don't
have to manage
that in your code;
centralized Cast session
state management;
and a reconnection service
that automatically handles
network issues to keep
your sender app connected
to the receiver.
Let's take a look at how
to add Cast to your app.
To load the JavaScript
library into your app,
add this script tag into
all pages of your app
which require it.
When the library is
loaded by the page,
it will call the
__onGCastApiAvailable callback
on the global window object.
So make sure to set that
before loading the library.
Now let's look at what this
initialization function should
do.
The Cast framework has a
global singleton object,
the CastContext,
which coordinates
all Cast interactions.
To initialize, you
must provide it
with a CastOptions object
using the setOptions method.
In the CastOptions object,
specify the receiver
application ID created in
the Cast developer console,
or use the default
media receiver app ID.
You can also set the
language, auto-join policy,
and whether to resume the saved
session in the CastOptions
object.
Before we move on, let's
talk about UI for a second.
Chrome provides a Cast
option in the browser menu.
But you can make the option more
easily visible to your users
by adding the Cast button
directly in your UI,
like your media
control interface.
The Cast framework provides
a button element for you.
Simply add it using the
is=google-cast-button property.
This button provides
the --connected-color
and --disconnected-color
styling attributes
for state color control.
Style this button as necessary,
and let the framework
handle the rest, like
visibility management
and click event handling.
Going back to the code, once
you've got the CastContext
instance, you can get the
current CastSession object.
The framework handles
maintenance of the session
and connection for you.
But you can listen for events
like media or volume changes
using event listener callbacks
set on the CastSession object.
All right.
Now that you've got
your CastSession object,
we can move on to
the fun stuff--
media playback.
Loading media onto the receiver
works the same as before.
The sender app has to
create a MediaInfo instance
with the URL and content
type of the media stream.
It then has to use this
MediaInfo object to initialize
a load request that can be
used by the loadMedia method
of the CastSession object.
Now that media has been
loaded, media playback
can be controlled with
the RemotePlayer binding.
Here's where the framework
API makes things super simple.
To control media playback,
initialize a RemotePlayer
object and use it to instantiate
a RemotePlayerController
object.
RemotePlayerController provides
methods to directly control
remote media playback, like
playing, pausing, stopping,
and more.
Let's take a deeper
look at these objects.
The RemotePlayer
object is actually
just a simple
state encapsulation
with no behavior of its own.
RemotePlayerController binds
the RemotePlayer object
to the device state
and sometimes uses
its property values and playback
control methods like seek.
Keep in mind that because
RemotePlayer has no behavior,
you can really use any
object you want which
contains the needed state.
This example in
Angular perfectly
demonstrates how easy it
is to hook the RemotePlayer
implementation into
your app, and how
these two objects can be used.
So how do you
monitor media status?
You can query the
RemotePlayer State
object, as mentioned
before, or you can directly
set event listeners on the
RemotePlayerController.
Some events, like playing or
pausing, muting, and volume
changes, can occur outside
of your app's control.
Your app will need
to act on the events
to synchronize itself
with the receiver
app on the Cast device.
Once the user has
finished casting,
they may disconnect your app.
Add a listener on the
RemotePlayerController
for the
IS_CONNECTED_CHANGED event
to update your app accordingly.
That's it.
That's everything you need
to Cast-enable your app.
You can get more details
about the Google Cast SDK
at developers.google.com/cast.
It's also important to take
a look at the Cast design
checklist, which has design
implications for your app.
We have also open-sourced
sample Cast apps
that you can use as a reference.
If you have any
developer questions,
post those on Stack Overflow.
Join our Google Cast developers
community on G+ to keep up
to date with SDK updates and
discuss with other developers.
I'm Sachit Mishra.
Thanks for watching,
and happy casting.